obviously now that we're finally past
the pandemic
i know you're able to you know get you
get get get the show money together most
definitely
it's uh is it is it like for you like um
because you know sometimes i'll see an
artist from like
i don't know the south right and you
know in the south or midwest they're
getting a stupid bag and then they'll
come out here to the west coast you know
specifically i'm talking about arizona
because i always book people in arizona
and they're they're trying to get the
same bag in arizona that they might get
in like you know people don't understand
that game you gotta understand that i
was just telling somebody about that
like uh
you know out here i'm able to charge
35 right so get it sell out no problem
but it'd be like i jump i'll jump a
couple states
and uh you know they get spicy you know
i'm saying the offers it trickled down
to 20 15 and it'd be like but i'm gonna
eat that up but i'm gonna eat that up
not not not for the not specifically for
the paper i'm gonna do that for that fan
base cause you wanna spread you wanna
spread your [ __ ] out man most definitely
so it'd be like even if it's that
long-term thinking yeah if i gotta go on
a run and do 10 shows for
i'm saying 15 000 on that side of the
field even though i'm getting 35 on this
side of the field i'mma still run that
concurrent i'm gonna run that concurrent
and not for the 15 000. i ain't really
doing it for the paper i'm doing it yeah
i'm saying so i could beat that
[ __ ] up they could become well
aware and very familiar with the fella
and then after that they're gonna
respect my gangster when i double back
and tell them i need 35. i'm saying and
so you know it's all a part of the game
once upon a time i was doing shows for
2500 it jumped to 5 000. bro i've seen
it with my own eyes come on this is the
name of the game so it'd be like even
the verses i don't even know i don't
even know your verse has got to be a
pretty penny these days same thing so
it's just it's just it's rap hustle i
respect the hustle so uh you know i
don't really complain you ain't gonna
hear me on the internet complaining too
much nor a person i ain't gonna complain
too much um i'm really just uh grateful
i'm grateful to even be in this position
you know i'm seeing me and uh you know
to be able to
reap the benefits off of something that
i do for free filming um have you are
you still like pretty active when it
comes to just selling versus like
because you know sometimes that can work
against you because maybe you water down
your brand a little bit nah most
definitely but when you're independent i
feel like you know it it it puts keeps
the lights on sometimes for sure um
i enjoy it all so now i ain't really i
ain't turning down nothing i ain't
turning down nothing there's never been
a song that's coming that's been so
terrible that you're like nah nah they
be coming
trash [ __ ]
like do not put me on primary artists on
this [ __ ] not you hear me
looking [ __ ] crazy hey but now they
come with anything they come with the
bag they come with the baggage claim and
uh so i'm most definitely jumping on it
get me right yeah i'm saying the song's
terrible
you'll be like i need a little more the
song is trash and they got more they got
everything they got the whole bag they
got what i asked for
i'mma knock it out
business is business what about the
video
business is business bro
i ain't gonna lie business is business
you got everything i don't go [ __ ] i
post that [ __ ] on my story one
time going about my business